qualquer pessoa só tem pokémon gol
finalmente está lá e agora do tipo
naquela fazem tem que escolher um
pokémon inicial eu já vi alguns vídeos
na net em curso ao frio pikachu com
pokémon inicial e oculto para caça de
picasso que vou tentar fazer isso também
quando mesmo brilhante disse ainda que o
limite que aparece pokémon
esta é a lógica é essa bola e ter sido
essa bola aí umas quatro ou cinco vezes
para que o dar um reset
já tô cansado tam cargo há oito anos 80
e isso não bugaighis correta ainda por
remo não correr
ana sca na capital se já não se espera
agora é o você outro lado a
jogar esta época
canalha especialmente para essa punição
caçamba hesperidina pokémon gol no
finalzinho pode queimar
como podem ver já fizemos duas vezes
ainda não por seu aplicativo pelos perto
estamos muito perto de ter o nosso
pikachu shine e amarelo com quatro anos
só escrevo e nos comentários quando o
pokémon vocês querem copa inglesa o meu
favorito eu ganhar aquilo fantasma kurt
boiger hotel e qualquer da 1ª série
assim isto sim é só a primeira série
primeira série que ela escolha mesmo da
van e trata muito quase muito quase
muito não aplica tinha um trabalho
eu acho carvalho e seu cachorro muito
bonito e esse tema onde sim é isso mesmo
vai vai vai ficar assim será e falei 'ai
meu nome é tomar gol
canalha é difícil apanhar um escopo mons
nunca ganhei pessoal foi boa
meu deus irá ser a senhora afirma
eu já vai pegar pikatchu pega o
jogo vinha to inicia vez que o cachorro
não pode aí é meu deus não podem tomar
gols caso e não podia ficar tim está a
passar um bom e muito obrigado
olha que tem aqui porque não olhei
pokémon nem tão pouco é um pouco esse
tópico da poker bolas e outras centenas
de ovos
é preciso estar aqui opina chutou e
mandou a equipe está com animação que
fique tudo aí ai' boop cachorro lei eu
só tem desde viana recebeu desde vila do
conde d eu tenho sentiu 30 mil clique
aqui e envie para acompanhar é o lucro e
não apontará quem aqui
aqui tá que tá aqui olha só agora está a
soma já peguei de primeira já faz bem o
problema
já peguei de primeira não tem hipóteses
a 14 vai poder mil
o fx foi iniciada mas não gera 10 mil
tudo já que ainda apanhou muito boy
vinha com a lei pokémon a aaa estamos
muito perto do aeroporto que só por aí
já 11 mil anos ac supostamente estar
conecta a descer aqui exato agora é só
girar né
boas meu deus encontramos pokémons bola
e festa dos pokémons na frente com quem
é é um radar e um peixinho no joelho
olha o gol no jogo o garoto mexicano já
tem três porque monge é isso melhor
mestre agora olha outros povos pokémon é
que posso ajudar muito pouco é muito
incerto e 5-1 agora não pelo o que eu
faço o tipo da pokémons tamanho é que o
ginásio já aqui mas lá no cu aposto que
alguma pessoa foi atropelada a procura
por semana
op stop está fora ué o que é tem que
estar mais perto
olá é que agora vamos tentar olha o lula
só o que uma senhora que esteve
supostamente estão era só um inicial não
acho que é por aqui
assim não é o contrário mas perdido acho
que é porque dá encontra já encontrei
alguns aqui pra curso qualquer
fantasma em cima do botafogo será o gol
do novo google através a competir sei lá
um peão pedir vai até a profissional é
só melhorar
já tenho pedir também meu deus sou muito
apanhar outro pokémons sem qualquer um
pode escolher tanto o meu deus ao esgoto
quase 500 ginásio é o metrô news
é isso aqui é este ginásio já que temos
um pé do metal nós vamos aproveitar e
beber uma cola bem gostosa bem fresca só
encontrou pokémon aqui queijos
commodities é muito pouco aqui já podia
esperar que eu acho que vai ser isso não
é nada
eu acho que vai ser pai porque eu pulei
superpolo três etapas de montanha
já peguei um homem agora vou encontrar
um pokémon dentro do mec tornou se fácil
agora só encontrei um pokémon muito
grande
olha a cara assim meu deus
ainda não pude ficar secando um sonho
foi aí que eu ganhei meu deus não pode
ser difícil
enquanto cp esse direito só agora estava
a tentar apanhar um pid e vejam só o que
aconteceu o google e ficou boa e grande
no tamanho móvel meu eo comeu do mario
olha aí eu vou tentar apanhar o google
mesmo olha aí saí de casa comigo pra
carai em grande a droga não acho que dá
pra perceber que o governo perceba que
calma acho que dá ó google ea china o
google
charles tipo podem encontrar um lar para
olha só além do rio lá pra
difícil o difícil vai apanhar apanha
apanha apanha apanha os 483
olha sou bem o corpo é mais forte que já
apanhei